[Musik]
der sitte april 2020 stellte in europa
einem entscheidenden wendepunkt in der
korona krise dar und zwar ohne dass dies
die meisten europäer irgendwie bemerkt
hätten eine jenem tag nämlich gab das
erste europäische land bekannt seine
infektions kurve erfolgreich abgeflacht
zu haben und die im kampf gegen das
virus eingeführten quarantänemaßnahmen
deshalb schrittweise zurückfahren zu
können
tatsächlich war es tschechien das als
erstes land europas eine exit-strategie
aus den zum schutz vor der solche
verhängten beschränkungen ankündigen
konnte und auch mit ihrer umsetzung
gegangen
[Musik]
wie war dies möglich geworden nun zwei
dinge waren dafür notwendig zum einen
musste die produktionszahl des virus
eher 0 dauerhaft unter den magischen
schwellenwert von 1 zu senken und zum
anderen muss das konzept der
intelligenten das heißt gezielten
quarantäne erprobt und die infrastruktur
und technologie dafür aus dem boden
gestampft werden beide bedingungen sind
hier nun erfüllt und daher sieht der
excel plan vor bis spätestens ende april
den schrittweisen übergang von den
flächen deckenden zu den intelligenten
also für die meisten bürger
verträglicheren quarantänemaßnahmen
abzuschließen natürlich ist der kampf
gegen das koma wir uns damit noch nicht
vorbei aber man merkt jetzt schon dass
tschechien die erste schlacht gewonnen
hat
[Musik]
zum zeitpunkt als wir dieses video dreh
gibt es in tschechien weniger als 6000
positiv auf kurven 19 getesteten
menschen und die zahl der verstorbenen
bei denen das virus zumindest
nachgewiesen würde liegt unter 130 wo
bei den meisten dieser menschen diese
infektion selbst gar nichts zum
verhängnis geworden sein dürfte sie sind
nur mit dem virus gestorben nicht wegen
ihm damit haben die tschechen in der
kroner krise rekordverdächtig gute
zahlen vorzuweisen aber wie haben sie
diese geschafft welche lehren könnten
andere aus ihrem beispiel ziehen in
diesem video werden wir euch alles
darüber erzählen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die tschechische republik ist ein land
das in den internationalen medien stark
unterrepräsentiert ist es sei denn man
betrachtet port hub als ein solches
bedeutendes medium denn dann könnte man
den eindruck gewinnen das malerische
prag sei der nabel der welt ja die
tschechische republik ist schon so etwas
wie das hollywood der
erwachsenenunterhaltung
[Musik]
aber es gibt noch sehr viele andere
erwähnenswerte dinge in diesem land die
ein eigenes wissen politik video werden
wer und eines davon ist ganz bestimmt
sein sieg im kampf gegen die stars kobe
2 pds ist zwar nicht alles vorüber doch
während fast ganz europa noch immer
unter quarantäne steht beziehungsweise
explodierender infektionszahlen aufweist
oder beides zusammen kann tschechien
jetzt aufatmen um euch eine vorstellung
vom ausmaß ihres triumphs zu geben
tschechien war eigentlich als crooner
her prädestiniert denn einerseits wird
jährlich von hunderttausenden
chinesischer touristen besucht und
andererseits waren auch die tschechen zu
tausenden in italienischen und
österreichischen alten zum skifahren
[Musik]
so auch in diesem winter und viele davon
haben cupid 19 mit nach hause gebracht
aber selbst unter diesen eigentlich
schlechten voraussetzungen kommen die
jetzigen infektions und opferzahlen noch
nicht mal in die nähe der alle
optimistisch sind prognosen die von den
experten so beginnt er solche abgegeben
wurden zum zeitpunkt als die regierung
den notstand ausrief sehr optimistisches
szenario 8000 interessierte bis zum
zwölften april vor allerdings wurden
bislang noch nicht mal 6000 infektionen
festgestellt und auch bei den
todeszahlen kann die solche nun unter
ferner liefen ab card werden dasselbe
gilt für die wirtschaft natürlich über
dieses land unter den auswirkungen der
garantien leiden und ines wird von der
erholung deutschlands abhängen denn aus
wirtschaftlicher sicht ist tschechien
quasi sein 17 das bundesland die
prognosen deuten jedoch darauf hin dass
die arbeitslosigkeit nicht höher als auf
fünf prozent steigen wird zurzeit sind
es lediglich 3 und wenn man sich fragt
warum ist so wichtig ist sich mit dieser
geschichte zu befassen dann muss man
verstehen dass dies eben nicht nur eine
erfolgsgeschichte ist sie kann uns auch
helfen zu verstehen was in anderen
ländern schon floss
denn sie stellt quasi das ein positiver
extrem dar und wir werden sie mit dem
anderen negativen extrem vergleichen
spanien außerdem können sie euch in
diesem fall eine vergleichende analyse
aus erster hand liefern denn falls ihr
unsere kanäle schon länger schaut werdet
ihr vielleicht festgestellt haben dass
die zwei visual politikredaktion eben in
prag und in madrid angesiedelt sind
meine kollegen und ich sind durch die
reisebeschränkungen nicht erst mal
voneinander getrennt und deren die eine
hälfte in madrid eine sehr schwere zeit
durchmacht kann die andere in prag nun
wieder der sonne entgegen sehen aber
abgesehen davon werden wir in diesem
video viele mythen aufräumen was das
erfolgsgeheimnis im kampf gegen das
corona dies betrifft beispiel
handyüberwachung im gegensatz zu
südkorea gibt es in tschechien strenge
datenschutzgesetze die eine weitgehende
überwachung der bürger verhindern eine
kroner tracking app wurde zwar schnell
entwickelt aber ihre nutzung war
freiwillig außerdem ist tschechien kein
besonders reiches land spanien und
italien verfügen über ein höheres
pro-kopf-einkommen zumindest war das vor
der krise noch der fall und manche
werden jetzt denken vielleicht sind sie
nicht reich aber sie geben wo
überdurchschnittlich viel für
gesundheitswesen aus aber nein auch das
trifft nicht zu schaut euch mal dieses
diagramm
[Musik]
hier seht ihr die gesundheitsausgaben im
verhältnis zum bruttoinlandsprodukt
sowohl spanien als auch italien stecken
mehr geld in ihre gesundheitssysteme als
die tschechische republik gut inzwischen
denken vielleicht einige von euch wir
würden jetzt anfangen über die
sauberkeit der tschechischen regierung
zu sprechen nicht war oder dass der
premierminister ein wahres genie sei
eine kreuzung aus winston churchill
nelson mandela und maske nein nicht ganz
tschechische premier minister wegen
korruptionsaffären unter druck ja das
habt ihr richtig gehört es ist von
korruptionsaffären der jeder im plural
die wahrheit ist dass der türkische
premierminister andré bisch so etwas wie
der böhmische berlusconi ist mehrfacher
euro milliardär eigentümer einer medien
holding und protagonist einer ganzen
reihe von korruptionsaffären die frage
die wir uns heute stellen lautet also
wie ist es möglich dass ausgerechnet
tschechien eines der wenigen länder ist
die es wirklich geschafft haben die
infektions kurve abzuflachen was hat
taiwan mit all dem zu tun und china
heute werden wir all diese fragen
beantworten aber lasst uns zunächst
einen blick in die geschichte werfen
[Musik]
das beste aus zwei welten bevor wir über
das coronaviren sprechen müssen wir uns
über gesundheitssysteme oder halten
während viele staaten der welt darunter
auch den usa noch immer gestritten wird
ob eine gesundheitsversorgung nach
europäischen vorbild der weisheit
letzter schluss ist oder aber
kommunistische des teufelszeug denken
selbst viele europäer das ist nur zwei
modelle der gesundheitsversorgung gibt
die staatliche und die private mit
anderen worten entweder stellen wir
sicher dass jeder zugang zur
gesundheitsversorgung hat oder
belassenen jeden das mit bezahlen wenn
er dazu überhaupt in der lage ist
[Musik]
doch der teufel steckt im detail es
stimmt dass alle europäischen länder die
allgemeine gesundheitsversorgung
sicherstellen je nach land gibt es
jedoch unterschiedliche system wir haben
euch diese weise in unserem letzten
video über corona bonns vorgestellt ihr
könnt euch dieses video ansehen wenn ihr
auf den link klickt er jetzt oben
erscheint aber noch mal kurz
zusammengefasst in ländern wie spanien
und großbritannien gibt es das
sogenannte beverage system in diesen
kümmert sich kurz gesagt der staat um
absolut alles und obwohl es dort auch
private krankenversicherungen geben kann
die für zusatzleistungen aufkommen
müssen die meisten bürger nur das lassen
sich gesundheitswesen und dieses ist
quasi ein monolith der direkt vom staat
verwaltet wird mit anderen worten erste
sind öffentliche bedienstete und die
regierung entscheidet wie viele
krankenhäuser gebaut werden und wie
diese ausgestattet sind außerdem bekommt
jeder bürger in diesem system seinen
arzt und sein krankenhaus fest vom start
zu gehen
[Musik]
und er fragt euch jetzt vielleicht
funktioniert dieses system die antwort
ist ja sowohl das vereinigte königreich
als auch spanien und dänemark verfügen
über qualität dieses system hat jedoch
zwei probleme das erste ist dass es in
der regel sehr lange wartezeiten gibt
die zweite ist dass man seinen arzt
nicht teilen kann auch wenn man ihn zum
beispiel gar nicht viele menschen in
spanien oder großbritannien die gar kein
anderes system kennen denken häufig dass
dies eben der preis dafür ist dass allen
bürgern eine allgemeine
gesundheitsversorgung zur verfügung
steht aber sie ehren denn es gibt ja
noch ein anderes system jenes das in der
tat das am weitesten verbreitete in ganz
europa ist wir sprechen über das
bismarck system das bis nach system
funktioniert in ländern wie deutschland
oder eben tschechien hier gibt es auch
eine öffentliche gesundheitsversorgung
aber sie wird nicht zentral vom staat
verwaltet dieser greift zwar regulierend
ein lässt aber bis zu einem gewissen
grad wettbewerb und diversität so auf
diese weise kann sich das
gesundheitswesen marktwirtschaftlich
selbst organisieren und damit viel
flexibler auf den bedarf der patienten
reagieren
denn im gegensatz zum beverage system
ist der patient nicht einem
monolithischen gesundheits koloss ohne
wahlmöglichkeiten ausgeliefert im
bismarck systemen stehen sich patienten
krankenversicherungen und
gesundheitsversorgung als mehr oder
weniger freie akteure gegenüber jeder
bürger kann zwischen verschiedenen
kanten versicherungen die für seine
bedürfnisse beste auswählen geben so
kann er unter den ersten und
krankenhäusern wählen
[Musik]
und die versicherung können mit den
ersten häusern und
medikamentenherstellern verträge und
bessere konditionen aushandeln mit denen
sie dann für ihre versicherten
attraktiver werden mit anderen worten
das business system ist das beste aus
beiden welten der staat garantiert eine
allgemeine gesundheitsversorgung für
alle aber gleichzeitig gibt es einen
wettbewerbsorientierten markt die
versicherer konkurrieren miteinander und
bemühen sich mit besseren leistungen
neue versicherungsnehmer zu gewinnen und
gleichzeitig konkurrieren auch die
krankenhäuser miteinander um patienten
anzuziehen dank dieses systems ist es
zum beispiel viel einfacher in prag
englisch oder deutsch sprachige erstes
zu finden ohne gleich ein vermögen in
einer privatklinik hinterlassen zu
müssen und ja ich weiß dass du dich
fragst was hat das alles mit dem corona
virus zu tun nun in einem system in dem
alles vom staat erwartet wird haben
krankenhäuser kaum autonomie und das
wurde in spanien zu einem großen problem
was ist dort passiert nun die regierung
hat die bedrohung durch des cola virus
und die damit verbundene belastung des
gesundheitssystems nicht ernst genommen
und das führte dazu dass so gut wie kein
krankenhaus in der lage war masken oder
beatmungsgeräte zu besorgen denn letzten
endes ist es die regierung die alles
zentral einkaufen muss in ländern mit
business systeme hingegen können sich
krankenhäuser und kliniken eigenständig
vorbereiten ohne auch ein plazet von
oben warten zu müssen aber einen moment
das war bei weitem nicht der einzige
unterschied zwischen tschechien und
spanien
liebesgrüße aus teil war soll sie die
eines tages wenn die großen wieder
geöffnet sind mahlgrad besuchen werden
euch vielleicht die vielen tibetische
flaggen auffallen die hier rum hin und
eventuell werdet ihr euch fragen was hat
prag mit liebe zu tun nun die prager
haben im jahr 2018 den vom chinesischen
regime am meisten gehassten man zu ihrem
oberbürgermeister gewählt es ist dieser
mann hier ständig schrieb er ist
mitglied der piratenpartei und schon
seit jahren einer der größten kritiker
des kommunistischen regimes in peking
habe vollkommen richtig gehört ich sagte
der piratenpartei erinnert sich noch
jemand von euch an die tja das ist ein
weiteres tschechisches kuriosum das
winzige island und in tschechien sind
die einzigen staaten in denen diese
bewegung die aus datenschutzskandalen
und dem verlangen nach
informationsfreiheit entstand noch eine
rolle spielt eigentlich schade oder
oder glaubt ihr etwa als hätte sich an
den von etwa 10 und julian assange
enthüllten praktiken etwas geändert nun
die tschechen glauben dass wohl nicht
denn die piraten sind die zweit größte
oppositionspartei im tschechischen
parlament und im prager stadtparlament
sind sie sogar die größte
regierungspartei woran dies liegt
vielleicht daran dass so viele tschechen
ausgesprochen liberaler tikis mit einer
gewissen sympathie für die legalisierung
von fünf konsum sind naja vielleicht ist
es auch nur ein klischee
aber zurück zu unserem chinakritischen
ober beraten im prager magistrat er gute
mann hat ist nämlich nicht leichtsinnig
betrieb leitet nicht nur einem
notorischen und für fremde zungen schier
unüberwindbaren vokal defizit in seine
vor und nachnamen nein er hat auch noch
überaus mächtigen gegenspieler denn wie
er sicher wisst ist die goldene stadt an
der moldau zu recht eines der
beliebtesten reiseziele der welt und
viele leute in prag verdienen sehr viel
geld an dem touristen aus china kamen
vor der krise jedes jahr über 600.000
davon und ließen viel geld in den prager
kassen für den ober tierarten betrieb
ist die tourismus lobby jedoch ein
gegner den er zum frühstück verspeist
ein ganz anderes kaliber ist dieser mann
hier das ist peter kern auf der liste
der reichsten menschen der welt belegt
er platz 68 tendenz steigend und mit
seinem vermögen von rund 50 milliarden
dollar ist er der reichste mann schätzt
zu seinem firmenimperium gehören
versicherungskonzerne medien holdings
telekommunikationsfirmen und homepage
eine komplett china ist das größte
verbraucherkredit unternehmen in china
mit über 60 millionen kunden und es ist
eine cash cow und könnt ihr euch
vorstellen dass es da ein ausländer in
china nicht unbedingt einfach ist ein
unternehmen ohne chinesische beteiligung
auszubauen dass dort zum marktführer zu
verbraucherkredite mit wucherzinsen wird
man braucht dafür eine lizenz und
eigentlich erlaubt ist china keine
ausländischen unternehmer eine solch
große und profitable firma allein zu
besitzen das heißt ohne chinesischen
teilhabe tja es sei denn man heißt elon
musk oder peter k und was ihr euch
sicher nicht vorstellen könnte ist dass
peking so etwas ganz ohne gegenleistung
erlaubt ja und die gegenleistung sieht
dann zum beispiel so aus
der song kreditfinanzierte pr kampagne
mit experten und journalisten zur
unterstützung rotchina das ist aber noch
lange nicht das ende der fahnenstange
denn im gleichen clicking fan klub
weekender sitzt auch der tschechische
präsident müller stemmer diesen hat sich
jeder schon vor einiger zeit gehandelt
denn tschechien stellt für das
kommunistische reicht ein perfektes
einfallstor zur einflussnahme auf die
ganze eu dar
seitdem verläuft die front dieses neuen
kalten krieges zwischen peking und den
westen mitten durch pracht deswegen sind
hier beide seiten die chinesische und
die china kritische hochgerüstet und
ausgezeichnet vernetzt und die
tschechische regierung gesellt sich mal
auf die einen mal auf die andere seite
je nachdem welche sie gerade braucht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist offiziell tschechische regierung
verbietet direktflüge nach china den
grund für das flugverbot könnt ihr euch
sicher vorstellen
19 aber so offensichtlich dies wird uns
jetzt klingen mag damals am 3 februar
2020 war diese entscheidung noch
hochgradig umstritten
tatsächlich war tschechien das einzige
land in europa das flüge von und nach
china verbot sogar die whu stellte sich
dagegen und kritisierte tschechien stars
achtet mal drauf wer was im februar 2020
gesagt
[Musik]
laut bka-chef sind keine flugverbote
notwendig und das china virus zu
bekämpfen und ihr werdet euch fragen
warum hat die türkische regierung damals
nicht auf den rat der whu gehört nun
vielleicht aus diesem grund
[Musik]
gerade bürgermeister dankt taiwan für
die bereitstellung von unterlagen zur
bekämpfung von kogit 19
das ist richtig taiwan stand das ganze
jahr über mit tschechien in enger
verbindung im grunde ist der prager
magistrat durch den bruch mit peking
eine partnerschaft mit taipeh die
hauptstadt taiwans eigentlich und diese
diplomatischen beziehungen haben sich in
dieser zeit als bisher nützlich erwiesen
am 7 märz erhielt prag alle studien und
strategie dokumente detail waren zur
bekämpfung des corona virus
ausgearbeitet hatte sowie taiwan
beispielsweise entgegen den empfehlungen
der whu zur flächendeckenden einführung
von mawson pflicht ferner an die
taiwanesen auch heraus welche art von
massentests am effektivsten ist so und
wenn man eine epidemie aus
wirtschaftswissenschaftlicher sicht
betrachtet kann man sie als ein
ungleichgewicht von angebot und
nachfrage verstehen plötzlich statt die
nachfrage nach gesundheitsversorgung bis
zur sättigung denn das angebot ist ja
begrenzt und nicht mehr in der lage die
plötzlich gestiegenen nachfrage zu
befriedigen was wäre also folglich der
erste und einfachste schritt um einer
solchen distanz vorzubeugen
man muss versuchen die nachfrage zu
reduzieren und genau das tat die
tschechische regierung so schnell wie
möglich
[Musik]
wegen der ausbreitung des corona virus
hat die regierung den notstand
ausgerufen und am zwölften märz 2020 die
präventivmaßnahmen weiter verschärft
zu diesem zeitpunkt gab es in der
tschechischen republik 116 bestätigte
fälle von coop 19 zum vergleich spanien
hat sich zum außen zu des notstands erst
nach überschreiten der 5000er marke
durchgerungen und dank dieser frühe
eingeleiteten maßnahmen ist die
quarantäne in tschechien wesentlich
reibungsloser und milder verlaufen als
in spanien
[Musik]
so durften blieb tschechien
beispielsweise die ganze zeit über im
freien spazierengehen radfahren oder in
zweiergruppen sporttreiben solange sie
eine atemschutzmaske punkt das mit den
mundschutz masken ist eigentlich eine
unglaublich schöne story an sich während
nämlich anderswo in europa noch wie wild
herum diskutiert wurde ob diese nun
sinnvoll sein oder nicht und auch die
bhu in einem chaotischen hin und her mal
davon abrät mal nicht handelten die
tschechien nämlich einfach maximal
pragmatisch wenn sie sahen dass gerade
in jenen ländern in denen masken ganz
normal getragen wurden in taiwan
südkorea und japan die ausbreitung des
virus am schlimmsten eingedämmt wurde am
anfang war es in tschechien zwar auch so
dass es eigentlich nicht genügend masken
gar wer für das gesundheitspersonal noch
für die ganze bevölkerung die regierung
geschafft über not kanäle zu welche aber
es reicht vorne und hinten nicht anstatt
sich aber nur darüber zu beschweren
krempelte das ganze land die ärmel hoch
setzte sich an den nähmaschinen und
produziert der mundschutz masken in
riesigen mengen den eigengebrauch für
das medizinische personal wie auch für
alle anderen bedürftigen eine ungeheure
leistung der zivilgesellschaft welche
auch psychologisch vielen menschen halt
deine trotz quarantäne und angst vor dem
virus wurden sich plötzlich von einer
riesigen welle sozialer wärme ergriffen
die alle menschen verband dabei ging es
nicht nur um die herstellung von masken
sondern auch um alles andere was die
menschen jetzt braucht es wurden
plattformen und dienste gegründet um
freiwillige mit hilfsbedürftigen zu
verbinden zum beispiel um ein käufer
surrender zu organisieren so dass diese
nicht mehr in den supermarkt gehen muss
diese plattformen halten auch künstlern
ihre auftritte auf einfache weise online
anzubieten und spenden einzusammeln
damit diese während des auftritts
verbots über die runden
[Musik]
einen entscheidenden beitrag leistete
auch die vietnamesisch der ringe
community während nämlich zur zeit des
kalten krieges die westeuropäischen
länder gastarbeiter aus den nahen osten
und nordafrika zu sich einladen aus
denen der großteil der dortigen
bevölkerung mit migrationshintergrund
entstand kam in die länder des ostblocks
vor wie gastarbeiter aus dem
kommunistischen bruderländer und
deswegen stammen in tschechien die
meisten menschen mit nicht-europäischen
migrationshintergrund aus vietnam und
sie sind bei der mehrheitsbevölkerung
äußerst beliebt denn sie sind bekannt
für ihren fleiß hohen bildungs und
integrationsgrad sowie ihre
außerordentliche expertise beim anbau
von qualitativ hochwertigen hanfpflanzen
den mundschutz masken aus hanffasern
sind doch die besten vor allem wer hätte
nicht gerne einer wie auch immer in
vielen fällen waren die mundschutzmasken
sehr einfach gehalten die regierung
machte es zur pflicht irgendeine art von
atemschutz zu tragen sobald man sein
haus oder auto verließ man konnte zum
beispiel auch einen schal benutzen
natürlich garantiert dass abdeckung von
mund und nase nicht dass man sich selbst
nicht anstecken kann aber es ist wahr
das ist eine barriere für die
wassertröpfchen in der atemluft
darstellen in denen sich die viren bis
hinten somit wird die ansteckungsgefahr
für andere verringert und auch hier
besteht das ziel nicht darin die
verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit ganz zu
stoppen sondern sie zu verringern und in
dieser hinsicht zählt jede maßnahme das
ausschlaggebende war die steigerung der
infektions kurve so früh wie möglich
abzuflachen
seht euch diese grafik
[Musik]
hier seht ihr die infektions kunst von
spanien im vergleich mit tschechien
tschechien ist es gelungen die nachfrage
nach krankenhausbetten schon ganz zu
anfang niedrig zu halten und was geschah
mit dem angebot es war unerlässlich
diese zu vergrößern atemschutzgeräte
beatmungsgeräte intensivbetten uns die
ganze ausrüstung zum schuss des
gesundheitspersonals zu beschaffen die
regierung machte sich wie verrückt auf
die suche nach lieferanten in china und
wie in anderen ländern wie zum beispiel
spanien ist auch tschechien opfer
einiger chinesischer betrüger geworden
[Musik]
80 prozent der von tschechien gekauften
cupid 90 schnelltests funktionieren
nicht
aber zum glück hat man sich nicht auf
die überteuerten und minderwertigen
hilfsgüter aus china verlassen müssen
die tschechische regierung konnte sich
zu jeder zeit auf ihre zivilgesellschaft
verlassen und hat versucht dieser keine
unnötigen bürokratischen hürden in den
weg zu stellen so hat beispielsweise das
türkische institut für informatik ein
eigenes modell einer atemschutzmaske
entwickelt dass sie mit jedem
handelsüblichen 3d drucker ausgedruckt
werden kann
die regierung zögerten keine sekunde
geben mit einem internetzugang und 3d
drucker dabei zu unterstützen
atemschutzgeräte auszudrücken und an
krankenhäuser zum spenden aber wieso ist
dies so bemerkenswert sollte dies nicht
eine selbstverständlichkeit sein nun in
spanien gibt es hier auch menschen mit
3d druckern und auch sie haben sich im
internet organisiert wo ist also das
problem nun aus irgendeinem grund den
ich nicht verstehe fand die spanische
regierung das gar nicht gut die selbst
gedruckten masken wurden verboten
madrid sagt nein zur solidarität der 3d
drucker einige tage nachdem sie
schutzmasken aus eigenproduktion noch
toleriert hatte erinnerte die
regionalregierung von madrid ihrer
meinung ohne die gründe dafür zu nennen
[Musik]
dank aller seiner maßnahmen konnte
tschechien seine kapazitäten an
krankenhauspersonal und intensivbetten
soweit schulen das ist mit diesen auch
anderen ländern helfen kann
[Musik]
die tschechische republik wird 619
patienten aus frankreich in einer
universitätsklinik behandeln um zur
entlastung des französischen
gesundheitssystems beizutragen
übrigens ist dieser fall verriet
zwischen europäischen ländern kein
einzelfall deutschland und luxemburg
behandeln auch französischen passieren
und wir werden wahrscheinlich noch viele
solcher fälle erleben wenn es mehr
ländern gelingt die pandemie einzuwenden
aber die frage die sich alle stellen
werden lautet was ist der nächste
schritt werden die beschränkungen
vollständig aufgehoben ist die
quarantäne beendet die antwort lautete
nein die strategie der nächsten phase
welche die tschechische republik nun
eingeleitet hat und die wahrscheinlich
in anderen ländern kopiert werden wird
ist die intelligente kantine auch smart
koren team genannt
[Musik]
tschechische republik will eine
intelligente quarantäne einführen durch
das tracking von handys und bankkarten
werden die gesundheitsämtern den
bewegungsdaten neuer corona virus
infizierter nachverfolgen um sie
identifizieren und isolieren zu können
dazu müssen die nutzer lediglich ihre
datenschutzrechtliche zustimmung
erteilen
[Musik]
die tschechische regierung kann doch
nicht die gesamte bevölkerung testen mit
dem know how aus anderen erfolgreichen
länder wie taiwan und südkorea hat sie
jedoch ein system entwickelt um das
gleiche ziel mit handy und kreditkarten
daten zu erreichen stellte uns vor ich
würde positiv auf kowitz 19 getestet
werden in diesem fall werde mich die
erste fragen ob ich damit einverstanden
bin dass das gesundheitsamt zugang zu
meinem handy ortungsdaten bekommt
natürlich alles auf freiwilliger basis
mit hilfe dieser daten kann das
gesundheitsamt jeden identifizieren mit
dem ich in der letzten woche
zusammentraf diese menschen können dann
schnellstmöglich getestet werden auf
diese weise müssen sich nur diejenigen
die positiv getestet wurden in
quarantäne begeben der rest der
bevölkerung kann ein normales leben
führen natürlich ist all dies mit einem
großen risiko verbunden weil die
regierung meine privatsphäre
ausschnüffeln kann auch wenn in den
bestimmungen und genau festgelegt ist
dass die daten nur für zwecke der
gesundheitsprävention verwendet werden
dürfen nun stellt sich die frage wer
tiere bereit eure bewegungsdaten von der
regierung auszeichnen zu lassen um im
gegenzug die einschränkungen für alle
menschen zu lockern
glaubt ihr dass euer land am ende auch
intelligente quarantäne maßnahmen
ergreifen wird wie schnell wird dies
geschehen und auf welche widerstände
könnte jetzt stoßen
wie würde so was euch persönlich
gefallen wie immer freuen wir uns schon
auf eure antworten und eine diskussion
auch höchsten er ist ischen niveau auf
die auch an arthur schopenhauer stolz
gewesen
und wenn ihr keines unserer aktuellen
update passen wollen abonniert bitte
visual politik und drückt auch auf die
klingel taste um immer rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt werden wenn euch dieses
video etwas gebracht hat geht uns auch
einen daumen hoch bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]